a shooting at round one at meadows mall  one person was shot after an argument  the shooter is on the run that is where  mary jane belliesa joins us with the  tense moments for employees as well as  shoppers  right now meadows mall remains closed as  police are investigating an incident  inside one witness we spoke to say  customers and employees ran inside her  store to shelter in place i didn't  really catch process what was going on  until i seen like everybody running like  stampedes into the store and then so  somebody's yelling they're shooting  they're shooting and i was just like oh  my god like i didn't have no like i had  to react in a way you know to get  everybody  safe like shelter so everybody started  running towards the back  right now we're still waiting on metro  to see what had happened inside we'll  bring you the latest details online and  on air as soon as we find out reporting  at meadows mall mary jane baleza live  local now